cours en ligne campus universitaires
fermés mes factures toujours aussi sale
et des étudiants se disent frustrés de
devoir payer le même prix qu'un vent
pour des services auxquels ils n'ont
plus accès à part une réduction de 50 %
pour les services auxquels nous n'avons
pas accès comme le centre sportif
le reste des frais n'a pas bougé ils ont
même augmenté des pétitions en ligne ont
été lancés et des associations
étudiantes se mobilisent pour demander à
leurs institutions d'au moins réduire
les frais afférents demande vraiment que
la facture étudiante cé à les payer et
qu'elle est yantian pas accès aux
services qu'ils soient remboursés
plusieurs universités disent avoir
ajusté les frais pour en tenir compte
mais seulement lorsque les services ne
sont plus du tout accessible certains
demandent aussi une réduction des droits
de scolarité
considérant que la qualité ne sera pas
la même en ligne l'apprentissage en
ligne met en avant une foule de nouveaux
obstacles dit elle les universités
soutiennent quant à elle que
l'enseignement virtuel est en train
d'être peaufinées et donnera les mêmes
résultats que les courants personnes le
ministère des collèges et des
universités de l'ontario ajoute que la
mise en place des cours en ligne a
nécessité des ajustements aux plates
formes en ligne et que cela a coûté cher
aux établissements il rappelle qu en
ontario les droits de scolarité pour les
étudiants canadiens sont gelées cette
année au québec en revanche les droits
de scolarité sont indexés mais le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur du
québec précise que les étudiants
québécois bénéficient de droits de
scolarité parmi les moins élevés au
canada et d'un régime dette financière
parmi les plus généreux le ministère
étudie actuellement les possibilités de
bonification du programme de prêts et
bourses
selon plusieurs associations étudiantes
c'est au gouvernement de contribuer
davantage et c'est l'amant de
financement gouvernemental qui fait que
l'éducation est inaccessible en ce
moment il ya eu des communications avec
l'enseignement supérieur à savoir
comment est ce qu'on pouvait aider les
universités
il en va de l'avenir et du bien-être des
étudiants distille mais aussi à long
terme de l'économie du pays
ici canif high rise and radio canada
toronto